I want to just take a step back to remind you what direction we're going in,
the iterative process, and what our end goal is.
One of the more common techniques to add context to our graphics and
data is the use of juxtaposition or comparison.
In the case of our scatter plot, we want to draw attention to
the games involving the home team by making them red and slightly larger so
that someone reading our graphic could compare them to
the games which don't involve the home country's team.
Doing so leverages some of the theory of pre-attentive processing by drawing
the reader to those games which do involve the home team so
that the audience can implicitly compare them to every other game.
Again, reminding you of the message of what we're trying to
convey is one of globalization and capitalization.
A priori, we may not know what effect making the home games red and
slightly larger will have, and whether or
not the comparison it creates helps communicate our message.
So let's go back to our web browser and see what effect this actually had.